y es que los demócratas tienen una
mayoría marginal a tanto en la cámara de
representantes como en el senado y este
proyecto entonces ahora pasa al senado
donde va a necesitar una mayoría simple
51 votos porque pasa como una ley de
presupuesto de reconciliación y así los
demócratas pues contarían con esos 51
votos teniendo en cuenta el voto de
kamala harris normalmente se necesitan
60 votos para poder aprobar este tipo de
iniciativas pero precisamente como es
una ley de reconciliación necesitará 51
solamente al respecto los republicanos
han dicho que este presupuesto es
bastante alto y que además es muy
general y por eso la oposición que
tendrá este proyecto de parte de los
republicanos en la cámara alta hay que
mencionar que después de ser aprobado
por el senado el proyecto de ayuda de
rescate económica de 19 billones de
dólares volverá a la cama
de representantes para un visto final y
después ir a la oficina del presidente
para que sea firmado como le he visto al
ver uno de los temas principales del
debate en cuanto a esta ley fue el
aumento del salario promovido por los
demócratas en qué consiste la propuesta
y cómo quedó entonces tras la votación
claro la propuesta es aumentar el
salario mínimo en eeuu a 15 dólares para
el 2025 sobre todo para las grandes
empresas sin embargo este proyecto no va
a poder pasar en el senado porque
precisamente ayer la parlamentaria
elisabeth mcdonald's le dijo a los
demócratas que en una ley de presupuesto
no se puede incluir este tema del
aumento salarial que es que va contra
las reglas del senado y la propia casa
blanca ya lo reconoció y dijo que
efectivamente pues sino en contra de las
reglas y que no iba a hacer nada al
respecto que simplemente se iba a
aferrar a las reglas y asumir esto como
una derrota lo que están haciendo
entonces los demócratas es empezar a
pues buscar soluciones a pesar de que
sabían que era que iba contra las reglas
los demócratas de la cámara de
representante aprueban el salario mínimo
y lo aprueban como dice analistas para
que el tema esté en la mesa de
negociación para que sea un debate que
se tenga que dar y lo que ellos quieren
entonces es
como solución empezar a poner
penalidades a las empresas grandes que
no paguen los 15 dólares la obra o
cobrarles más impuestos para que los
americanos pues puedan según ellos
recibir un salario mínimo base que no
les que les permita vivir con este
salario y no tengan que trabajar para
seguir en la pobreza